let's take a look at this live shot this
is the scene of the disaster right now
in the city of petropolis just north of
rio de janeiro this is the area hardest
hit by the disaster and the death toll
is expected to rise there kache lopez
hodolyan has more on this
the force and magnitude of this rainfall
was unexpected within hours streets
across the brazilian city of petropolis
were submerged
[Applause]
nearby families are stunned as floods
and mudslides get closer to their homes
[Music]
the current so strong it pushed vehicles
along streets like toys
even a bus is aimlessly dragged away
nearly covered in water
this group desperately tries to hold on
the local fire department says more than
250 millimeters of rain fell within six
hours that's more than the monthly
average for the entire month of february
the region is still recovering from the
damage of last year's heavy rains where
more than 500 people were killed
this year again authorities fear the
death toll will likely rise
recovery efforts are underway
president haid bolsonaro who's visiting
russia has called on the local
government to deliver immediate support
to what will likely be a long-term
operation
katya lopez obayan al jazeera